Russia says that it thwarted a Ukrainian
attack on one of its reconnaissance ships.
But there's new video.
Is that true?
What they said
Well,
it seems as though it potentially isn't.
The Ukrainian certainly have
a very different point of view of that.
Now, it seems they have the video,
but it seems to back that up.
And you're absolutely right.
At first the Russians had said
that there was an attack with sea drones.
Those are essentially unmanned surface
vessels on one of their main intelligence
ships in the Black Sea.
And the Russians showed a video of
their ship destroying one of those drones.
But the Ukrainians came with a video today
which seems to show another drone moving
towards that ship and coming towards
that ship, potentially hitting it.
We're not sure what exactly the damage is,
but in that video,
which is quite dramatic,
you can see someone from the Russian ship
firing at that sea drone,
seemingly trying to stop it.
And this potentially could be a big blow
to the Russians because, of course,
it shows on the one hand
that their ships really aren't safe
from the Ukrainians in the Black Sea,
but also the ship that was hit.
It's called the Ivan Horse.
And it's actually one of the most modern
intelligence ships that the Russians have.
It only went into service in 20, 20, 18.
So that potentially in itself
could be a big blow and another big
blow to the Russian
navy in the war against Ukraine Jake.
All right, Fred Pleitgen in Kiev, Ukraine,
thanks so much.
A series of drone and missile strikes
reported across Ukraine,
including the capital region of key
president.
Zelenskiy says a medical facility was hit
in the central Ukrainian city of Dnipro.
16 people are reported injured including
a six year old and a three year old.
Military officials say the they downed
most of Russia's 17
cruise missiles and 31 attack drones.
Meanwhile, in Russia, a large explosion
was heard overnight in the city
of Cranston DA
and a building was damaged there.
The governor of Belgorod
is also reporting shelling.
He says four homes were damaged.
There were no casualties
reported so far from that.
Let's go to Sam Kiley.
He's live in eastern Ukraine with more.
Sam, what can you tell
us, especially those children
Well, once
again, a large city like Disney
Pro has been hit at the moment.
The casualty figures lower
than some of the more atrocious strikes
which have been directed at
or at least fallen upon
residential buildings,
particularly in Disney Pro.
This one, as you say, he's got 16 wounded.
There are four people missing.
One confirmed dead in this missile strike,
which Ukraine's
first lady has described as a cynical act.
To be honest,
the fact of the matter is that
the Russians are profligate
in their attacks across civilian areas.
Right across the country.
Sometimes their aim,
sometimes they're simply firing
into the landscape more generally
with the hope of hitting something.
This may well be a fall into that latter
category.
But at the same time,
the Ukrainians continue to try to rattle
the Russians behind the border.
Now, with Russia, with reportedly more
shelling from Ukraine into border areas,
countering the shelling
that has come in for months now
from day
one of the war from those border areas
into Ukraine along the northern border,
particularly in Belgorod Province.
And then we've got this mysterious
explosion or fire much deeper into Russia
with no confirmation
from either side really
as to what has been the cause of that.
But all of this part of a pattern
really in which
the Russians continued to hit
civilian targets inside Ukraine
while the Ukrainians is continuing
to try to destabilize the Russia
as part ultimately of the early stages
of a summer offensive.
Sam Kiley in eastern Ukraine,
appreciate your reporting.
Thank you.
Something we're following.
We're getting reports of an explosion
in the Russian city of Krasnodar.
Now social media videos
geolocated by CNN show
what appears to be a building on fire.
You see it there.
Video also appears to show a drone
in the sky, followed by sound of a blast.
Russian state news outlets
say there are no reports of casualties
and emergency services
have been sent to the scene
because order is located
about 240 kilometers
or 150 miles
east of the occupied Crimea peninsula.